72 معاق بدون رقابة، تعلم أنه من الصعب عدم القيام بذلك
أنا لا أعرف بعضنا البعض لذلك اسمحوا لي أن تظهر لك
فيديو كان على قناة التلغرام هذه انتبهوا فهمنا
ضع كل شيء عليك واجلس
تحية ابني لجميع الوحدات
الاستعداد قصة نفسية ليانيف كوبويتز معنا
في إسرائيل، تم نشر الحاج قبل شهرين من تزا ليبيل
قناة التأثير هذه القناة
في Telegram حيث يتم استخدام أقسى الكلمات بالفعل
وأسوأ الصور تظهر كيف هم الجوارح
ويمدحه الإرهابيون وكل هذا يقوله الجيش بعد ذلك
نحن لا نديرها ولكن منذ بعض الوقت
يعترف يميم بأنه نعم نحن من كذب هناك
لشخص ما في قسم العمليات
في الجيش، أريد أن أصدق أن رئيس قسم العمليات
في ميتشال، عوديد باسيوك، الجنرال عوديد باسيوك، الذي يقول
لم أكن أعرف بصراحة ما هو القسم
ويوجد تأثير في شعبة العمليات في مقر الإدارة
يُسمى بقسم التأثير، وهو يستخدم كل شيء
الأساليب البسيطة التي تعتقد أنها تؤثر عليه
العدو الآن ماذا حدث منذ كارثة العودة
في أكتوبر الناس الذين ربما اتخذوا مبادرة خاصة
لذلك أنشأوا قناة على تيليجرام تحتوي على مواد التشاليم
الذي ركض هكذا بين القوات بين الجنود
ويتخذ الجمهور الإسرائيلي المواقف الأكثر يمينية
التشدد لأنني لا أعرف الآن أنه يؤتي ثماره
لنا لمنظمةسكو
في الباش الاستخباراتي الذي أدى إلى العودة في أكتوبر إيه
لقد رأينا قبل ساعات فقط مدى القوة التي يتمتع بها المستوطنون
وعلمت "إهدوت" أمس أن إسرائيل شاركت في مناورة
شراء اختطاف فلسطيني من قبل المستوطنين
نجحت ممارسة القيادة المركزية هذه في الإزعاج
وطبعا المستوطنون بشكل عام هم اليمينيين لماذا
ممارسة شيء لم يحدث لم يحدث أبدا
مستوطن لم يخطف طفلا عربيا، نعم الوزير سموتريش
عضو الكنيست ستيلات برين وعضو الكنيست تسفي
سوكوت ووزير الأمن الوطني إيتمار بن جابر
ليست هناك سابقة، لذلك سنمضي قدماً، ولا سابقة للمستوطن
أي أن المستوطن في يهودا والسامرة هو أمر صحيح ولكنه صعب
إن القول بأن الأمر قد حدث بالكامل في الخيال يتطلب ثلاثة
اليهود يوسف حاييم بن داود من سكان القدس
وأخذه قاصران من بيت شيمش إلى الغابة
القدس وهنا أحرقوه ومحمد ما زال حيا
تم اختطاف المتسلل وقتله في صيف عام 2014 على يد السكان
القدس وبات شيمش ليسا من سكان يهودا والسامرة
لهذا سنضيف إسرائيل إلى درمان ش
في عام 1988 حُكم عليه بعشر مشروط لتورطه
في حادثة كتب خلالها طفل فلسطيني في أحد المنازل
ليهم وسيناريو آخر حيث كان هناك ابن الوزير أوري
سمح لستروك زفي ستروك بالاختطاف والإساءة
وفي عام 2011، حُكم على الفلسطيني بالسجن
في الممارسة العملية لمدة عامين ونصف، جنرال القيادة المركزية
يهودا فوكس يعتذر عن المحادثات التي أجراها خلال النهار
والأخير مع رؤساء المجالس في يهودا وشمرون أيضًا
رئيس الأركان هرتسي هليفي ينشر إعلانًا منذ فترة
باختصار يقول أيضًا آسف لكل من أصيب
ومن هذا المنطلق يقول رئيس الوزراء نتنياهو إن هذا منفصل
من الواقع فهو غير مناسب ويثقل كاهل الجمهور
من الواضح من يشير إليه باسم نادر جدًا
أن يصدر رئيس الوزراء رأي إدانة استباقي وكانوا
لديه الكثير من الأسباب للقيام بذلك منذ تشويه اسمه
لرجل البيك الذي حوله إلى خائن من الهجوم
رئيس الأركان لكنه اختار أن يفعل ذلك بالكامل
ويعود رفض حماس لهذا العرض إلى سبب سياسي
على جدول الأعمال إعطاء الموافقة لقوات الدفاع الإسرائيلية
إن مواصلة العمل الآن حتى في رفح أمر غير مقبول
وهي ضرورة بقدر ما فيها ضرر ووفقا لهذا الحكم
وقف الحرب تماما ثم ربما لا
ستكون هناك صفقة وهذا يعني في النهاية أن المساحة الأخيرة
توزيع الورق الأخير الذي لم يلعب فيه Tzahal القاع بعد
في قطاع غزة، الوضع سيء ولكن هناك هدر كبير هنا
لا يوجد حتى الآن مخطط تفصيلي لكيفية القيام بذلك أيضًا
وأن هناك 1.2 مليون لاجئ من غزة هناك، وأيضاً بسبب ذلك
وأن التوترات مع مصر لم يتم حلها بعد بطريقة أو بأخرى
إنهم يفعلون كيف يعملون هناك في الأسفل بدون
أن مئات الآلاف يقفزون السياج من أجلهم الآن
والدخول إلى أراضي مصر لم يعد هناك اتفاق معه
سيعمل المخنث بعد هاني ونيس تسيل في فترة الإعارة
كيف سيعمل في رفح حتى الآن دون إجابة كهذه يا سيدي
غانتس داف نيل كتب لنا انتقادا لنتنياهو
في سلسلة من القضايا حيث وجه
غانتس قبل كل شيء قبل دقائق قليلة من جولة أخرى
تبادل الأسماء بين نتنياهو وغانتس
في المصطلحات التي لا نسمعها عادة
ويقول نتنياهو إن غان مخطئ في اعتقاده أنه مسؤول
الإذن باستبدال حماس إذا أتوا
النصر ليس له بديل عن النصر المطلق هذا الشيء
غانتس يخرج عن رباطة جأشه بسبب ما يقوله وما يقوله
أن رئيس إسرائيل نتنياهو مشغول باختراعات ليست كذلك
قالوا إنه يتباطأ ويسمح لحماس بالعودة
القدرات: يضرب أهداف الحرب عندما يفعل ذلك
هذا ما قاله أحد أعضاء مجلس الوزراء عن رئيس الوزراء
بالتأكيد التصعيد في هذه العلاقة الليلة
وهذا بعد كما ذكرتم مؤتمر صحفي فيه
ويهاجم غانتس نتنياهو في كل قضية
والأمر الجوهري على المحك هو أيضا قضية المختطفين
في اليوم التالي لتقديم المساعدات الإنسانية I
بالطبع، أنا لا أتحدث عن المركز الثامن عشر في الكنيست، الذي يؤيده أيضًا
المشار إليها، كما أنها تمثل التطبيع كهدف
ويمكن القول أن القوة المركزية هي القوة الأيونية في حال وصول غانتس
إلى استنتاج مفاده أن إسرائيل في طريقها إلى صفقة اختطاف أخرى
ومن ثم من أجل التطبيع، أعتقد أنه سيبقى
وأن هذه الأمور سوف تتضح للجميع قريباً
وفي بداية الشهر المقبل، إذا لم يكن الأمر كذلك، فلن يفعل
سيبقى في الحكومة ولو على مراحل
ما يلي من لحام هذه الحكومة سوف تستغني عنه
معسكر الدولة